-Our first guest tonight
is an Oscar-nominated,
Golden Globe-winning actress
you know from films like
"American Hustle" and "Vice", as
well as HBO's "Sharp Objects".
She stars in "Dear Evan Hansen",
which is in theaters
September 24th.
Let's take a look.
-I mean, most people think
that I'm... [clicks tongue]
not that cool of a person, so
nobody wants to hear from me.
-Well, it --
That's what most people think.
Sounds like most people
don't know you very well.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Didn't know Connor, either.
They never bothered.
-Please welcome back to the show
Amy Adams.
Hello, Amy.
It's always good to see you.
-Hi, Seth! It's good to
see you, too.
How are you?
-I am wonderful.
This is now the third time I've
been lucky enough to check in
with you remotely, and I want to
just see where we're going
as far as hobbies.
I feel like early on,
we were messing around
with stringed instruments.
Felt like maybe...
-Yeah.
-...We abandoned that one.
-I did. I did aban--
Well...
Yeah, did. Yeah, I didn't --
-OK, thank you.
It felt like you were going to
maybe say no,
but then you came -- you found
your way to the truth.
-I did. I was going to maybe
baby lie on that one,
and then I thought,
"No, the truth is easier."
-Yeah.
-Then we talked a little about
dancing -- I feel like
your daughter really has
the skills that maybe made
you think,
"She's my daughter. I probably
have the skills, too."
How's the dancing going?
-Dancing's going okay.
I had been dancing for a film
that we'll talk about later,
but I thought, "Okay,
I'm going to get into
this TikTok thing."
-Very wise. Very wise.
-Which is mortifying for her.
I'm not on TikTok,
and so the only TikTok dance
that I have
even partially learned is
from the Applebee's commercial.
Because I -- [ Laughs ]
I don't know
if you know
that song "Fancy Like".
-Yes. Walker Hayes.
Yes. We had him here doing it.
Yes.
-I'm always behind on
everything,
so I actually thought that was
just an Applebee's commercial.
-Right.
-So.
-That really is -- you're right.
That's when you know your age,
is when you -- you think
it's from the commercial.
-That Applebee's jingle
is really catchy.
Yeah, but the dance
is catchy, too,
so that's the only one
I've actually learned.
-Can you? Can you, from
a sitting position,
is there any of that
you can show us,
as far as what
that TikTok dance is?
-I can try.
-OK, great.
-OK. ♪ Yeah, we're fancy like
Applebee's on a date night ♪
♪ Got a Bourbon Street steak
and an Oreo shake ♪
♪ Got the whipped cream on
the top, too ♪
♪ Two straws, one check,
yeah, I got you ♪
It's -- What's happening down
here is just as good.
So you can just --
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
Will you just send us
a tape of that later?
And we'll marry the two.
-Sure, sure.
-How now --
Your daughter is how old?
-That's not embarrassing at all
for my daughter,
what I just did.
-Well, that's what I was
going to ask.
How is -- How is she responding?
By the way,
they say you probably --
it's not safe
to do a TikTok dance
if you're old enough to have
a row of vinyl behind you.
[ Laughter ]
-This is probably true.
This is probably true.
-How does she feel
when you do your dances?
-I think the word
she uses is "cringe."
-Oh, no.
-But she's patient with me.
I've been embarrassing her
for 11 great years,
and, you know, more to come.
-Think you have way much more to
come.
-Yeah.
-This is really cool.
I know that you were,
like many people,
a huge fan of "Dear Evan Hansen"
when it was on Broadway.
It must be so nice
to be involved in this project
now that it's on film.
-It's amazing. I'm so honored
to be a part of this.
It's got such beautiful
messaging,
beautiful, talented actors,
and again, I'm just honored
to be a part of it.
Broadway and stage
is my first love,
so it's nice to get to
honor it in this way.
-I'm sure people are often very
nervous and excited to meet you,
but this was the reverse, when
you got to work with Ben Platt
because you'd been so blown away
by him on stage. Is that right?
-Yeah, I was -- I was very --
I -- It's weird
because it's intimidated,
but it's only by his talent
because his -- as a human,
he's just so gracious
and wonderful.
But yeah, it was -- it was --
to, like, sing in front of him
at our first table read
was terrifying.
But again, he's so gracious.
I mean, because he shows you
what's possible,
and then you sing,
and then it's what you do,
which is different, you know?
-He shows you what's possible
for Ben Platt.
I think that is maybe a fair way
to put it.
-That's fair.
-Did you enjoy getting to
spend time with, you know,
what must be --
you know, obviously,
this is a show where
a lot of the cast
are played by younger people.
-Yeah, I -- I mean,
I say that --
that sounded doubtful.
I love them.
But again, I get so excited,
and Kaitlyn Dever was someone
that I had been sort of...
online pursuing.
I don't like the "S" word,
but I was sort of getting
to know all about her online,
and really,
really love her work.
She's a beautiful singer.
And then we met.
I sort of gushed all over her.
And then we did have
some musical things in common,
so then I thought, you know,
"I'm just as cool as her,"
which I'm not, so.
-Did you bring that back
and report that to your daughter
as evidence
that you're a cool young person?
-Yeah, I would say --
Kaitlyn knows who Brett is,
so I must be cool.
-And then did her
just, like, eyes glass over?
She -- You know what?
She's at this place
where she's actually
really kind to me about it.
Like, she can see my struggle
and she kind of --
she's patient with it.
-I think that means you're a
good mom, that you've raised
such an empathetic daughter
who feels so deeply for
her cringy --
her cringy mom's feelings.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I'd like --
I'm going to take that as a win.
-So this is -- we talked about
this a little bit last time
you were here. I'm sure
it's further down the line now,
but you're doing "Disenchanted",
which is a sequel to
"Enchanted".
This is a very, you know --
a long gap between the two.
Has it been just a delight
to return to the character?
-It has been wonderful.
That's the film
I was talking about,
that I was training
and dancing again for.
It's been wonderful.
She's -- Returning to Giselle,
she's such a positive attitude
and so much energy
and really always tries
to see the best in people,
and that's something I always
try to remind myself to do,
so it's nice to return to her.
Different.
-I also -- I feel like you took
on a hobby that, like,
unlike learning
to play the cello,
was one that
you could accomplish.
It's one for other people
to accomplish.
And I'm actually -- when I heard
that you were doing it,
I'm like, "I think that sounds
pretty good."
You started binge-watching
"Murder, She Wrote".
-I did.
I love "Murder, She Wrote",
and next on the list is
"Matlock".
Maybe I'll get Kaitlyn Dever
to watch it with me.
[ Laughter ]
There's a reason.
We'll talk about it sometime.
I know. But when I did -- when
I used to do dinner theater,
I didn't have cable,
and so the only thing on
when I got home at night --
it was like 11 or 12 --
was "Matlock"
and "Murder, She Wrote".
So I'm now revisiting those.
-I think it's a really nice
bookend
that we started
talking about TikTok
and we ended
talking about "Matlock".
[ Laughter ]
-Kind of. Well, yeah.
That's a little peek inside
there, Seth.
-Hey, it's always so great
to see you.
Next time -- I'm feeling very
confident next time
is going to be in person.
-Yes, 100% will make
that happen.
-All right, great,
thanks so much, Amy.
-And then you can
see the feet.
-Oh man, you better --
don't oversell it
because we are going to --
-OK, OK.
-We're going to take a real look
at these feet. [ Laughs ]
-OK, fair enough.
-"Dear Evan Hansen" is in
theaters September 24th.